i think
when the pandemic happened where people
were forced to be around each other
some people realized i really don't
enjoy your company that much
okay and it's unfortunate because at
least
when you only see somebody at night or
whatever
it's an hour you can tolerate the person
but if you're in pandemic you're in
shutdown mode for six months and you're
bill gates who at the time even though
you're not a doctor you're one of the
voices second to anthony fauci that what
the world should do
and your wife melinda is next to you
who's also got a pretty big ego just as
much as you and you guys are stuck in a
50 million dollar house for freaking six
months
i wonder what those fights would be like
you know i wonder what those fights were
looking like i wonder how annoying they
were to each other and eventually
they're like dude i just
i'm good not being around you anymore
well think about how high her profile is
today compared to what it was say five
years ago i mean
she's done so many interviews she's
become
such an advocate for women and
so but she's not even comparable to
mckinsey right as far as the voice goes
as far as they're in different leagues
and that's why i mean i i think that
that that she would have never as an
influence
not even close no no no no no melinda's
way ahead
she's there as i'm saying she was behind
she was your opportunity the lawyers
crafted the tweet
the lawyers crafted the tweet that they
both wrote melinda i promise you made
sure
that they're going to continue
co-running the the foundation
and they're going to because she's not
giving up her leadership position she's
got she's got a taste for power and
she's
not giving it up she's extremely
ambitious from ursuline
to remember she's using bezos's
attorneys
she's using trump's former attorneys so
she
is in it to win it and she's not going
to give her give up the power you think
she called trump and said i need a
referral
i'm thinking no can i get a referral
donald
we're focusing a lot on her where do you
think those minds she's impressive hang
on a second
melinda gates is very impressive and i
think she honestly believes in things
she's doing i saw she was running a
massive division of microsoft
yeah and also i saw her talking about uh
the uh the malaria eradication project
was one of the first
of the gates foundation there's no
question she's a true believer
and she was a true believer i saw her
interview she was interviewed by
kara swisher and i was really impressed
i said wow
there's passion there's how there's when
there's who else i need i was like wow
this is like listening to the business
plan for
malaria eradication i was really
impressed it wasn't just
it wasn't just the celebrity that
questions picture favorites that shaved
the
animals shut up brilliant question for
you tom not that either is going to do
it
but which of the two would you think
deep down inside
has more aspiration of wanting to become
the president united states melinda or
bill gates
i have my own opinion what do you think
well if you narrow it down to that
question i think it's melinda i agree
with you
i agree with you i think she's more
aspirational and more ambitious to want
to do something like that
and he was never a power executive he
was always a thinker
and he understood the power of some
meltdowns so he's had some great epic
meltdowns
he also understands the power of
platform yeah and so when he and jobs
were together
he understood platform he understood
monopolistic power he understood exactly
what he was doing with the
what became the wintel standard whereas
jobs was about
design about innovation about being very
different
about being on the edge and not being
we need to this is the matrix not being
the right there's a there's a
wide age gap between those two as well i
mean bill gates is 65. he's in a
different place in his life he hangs out
with
he you know he and warren buffett are
buddies i mean it's how old is she
playing gin rummy playing gin right now
i pull her up i i
she's probably in her mid-50s probably a
10-year age i think she's 56
okay so there's a nine-year age gap
all right that's not that big of a deal
did we kai check it
yeah okay okay we're showing melinda a
lot of love respect i get it but where's
bill at right now
give me a word biz doc where's bill's
mindset at
i think it's totally fine yeah i think
bill is totally fine
how can you not be at peace with 75
billion
but i tell you it's not even the money
part it's there's
also an element of imagine their debates
[Music]
imagine bill's identity i was like dude
i've been the richest man in the world
for freaking 30 years
until these guys showed up you realize
who i am like everybody's been talking
about me for a while
you and i were you weren't there day one
you ran a division great we met we
hooked up
all good respect you you were somebody
that did a great job with the company
but
i'm bill gates you know i am bill gates
i've done
a lot of stuff the foundation is named
after me let's not forget it it's gay
that's kate
i know it's bill melinda gates but it's
but it's gates is the last thing
oh geez so to him his identity
you don't think there is like a bunch of
girls out there who are like scientist
type of girls that are
you know into soci sexual homosexuals
who are like oh
my god gosh get me that sapiosexual i
want them right now
i mean there's a big there's a tender
site for sapiosexuals
what's it called i don't even know but
it's a good idea what are the chances he
just rolls up with like this hot
model scientist you know what that's a
good one the chances he goes down that
very low
the un underserved
wow think about it somebody right now
listening to this run with it
and let us know about it five years from
now when you go ipo 4 billion nerd match
can you imagine that if there's a dating
site specifically for
well look minimum requirement to be on
this dating site you have to have a 4.5
gpa like imagine it's like one of those
elite brilliant genius rocket scientist
type of a community if they've got one
for farmers they can have one for
sapiosexuals wasn't there one that was a
six-figure club ladder where you would
travel and meet each other at airports
the what was it called ladder it was a
dating site specifically
for those six figure and up executives
that was specifically their market
target market that's one way to filter
i think but by the way i tell you what i
like about that it was the whole idea
was you're so busy you don't have time
to date which
a lot of people nowadays you're an
executive you're running a gun and
traveling you don't have time to date
here's a website find a way to you know
connect and have a cup of coffee
together and maybe you know i mean
look at one of the most popular shows
that's been on tv in in recent history
big bang theory i mean
that went for season after season after
season
sapiosexuals are a thing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you